[Musique]
oh
le mur celui qui visite aujourd'hui
berlin et fatalement confronté au mur je
l'étais et je crois que je ne
l'oublierai pas quand on roule dans
berlin
quand on marche dans berlin fatalement
on se heurte au mur que l'on aille vers
le nord que l'on aille vers l'est vers
l'ouest vers le sud on arrive toujours
au met
et il est il est là devant soi
monstrueux effrayant des plaques de
béton préfabriqué surmonté par des
rondeaux parce que c'est en deux ans
empêche les grappins de s'y attacher
et puis quand on se hisse sur les
nombreuses plateformes qu'on a placés çà
et là pour que l'on puisse voir de l'ap
quand on monte sur ses plateformes et
bien on aperçoit le no man's land
le groupe terrible avec ses chevaux de
frise avec ses airs ce
e
on
et l'on sait que ce no man's land est
miné
[Musique]
et puis derrière il y a les miradors
régulièrement posé avec les faux peau
les policiers de l'allemagne de l'est
armés de fusils et avec leurs jumelles
qui regardent sans cesse
[Musique]
et
et puis l'on sait qu'il y a tout le long
du mur 270 jeunes il emplit de chiens
policiers
et si quelqu'un tente de passer on les
lâche ses chiens
et puis au delà et là on en croit passer
au delà il y à 1 seulement c'est cela le
mur de berlin
[Musique]
le
alors quand on arrive à bien on est
persuadé parce qu'on a toujours vu qu'il
ya un mur qui sépare berlin est de
berlin ouest
on trouvera mur qui sépare en effet les
deux zones c'est vrai il existe il a 46
km2 mais il faut être sur place pour
comprendre parce que en fait berlin
ouest n'est pas seulement en contact
avec la zone est de berlin la zone
soviétique berlin ouest de l'autre côté
est en contact avec la république
démocratique allemande
alors le mur se continue autour de
berlin en fait berlin c'est une
citadelle
c'est une forteresse encerclé par un de
ses remparts comme ce que jadis vauban
place et autour des villes et les
berlinois de l'ouest sont en quelque
sorte dans une nasse dans une souricière
encore ces gens là peuvent ils sortis de
berlin ouest ils ont librement le droit
de prendre le train de prendre un avion
de prendre une voiture rien et
autoroutes pour aller en république
fédérale allemande il y en a une tout au
moins
mais les berlinois de l'est et les
allemands de l'est ne peuvent pas entrer
d'un berlin-ouest voilà toute la
différence
berlin ouest leur est interdit c'est
pour cela qu'on l'a construit le mur
[Musique]
et les berlinois de l'est et les
allemands de l'est quand ils voient ce
mur pourrait penser à dante élire une
inscription de feu imaginait sur ce mur
vous qui voyait le mur perdez toute
espérance
c'est cela le mur de berlin
46 kilomètres dans la ville et en tout
tout autour 162 km
[Musique]
depuis 1961
je vais chercher des gens qui vivent
dans les pays de l'est pour les ramener
ici vers la liberté
je ramène les gens qui ne peuvent pas
franchir ce mur je fais comme je vous le
dis depuis 1961 et jusqu'à ce jour il
faut dire que jusqu'à ce jour
tout s'est bien passé et leur
connaissance de ces gens correspond
évidemment au service que je leur ai
rendu
j'utilise de faux passeports j'utilise
d'autres moyens et jusqu'ici j'ai
toujours réussi à ramener ces gens
lorsqu en 1961 le mur a été construit il
était pour chaque paire minois de son
devoir d'aider les gens de l'autre côté
lorsqu'il n'y avait que du fil de fer
barbelé pour qu'il puisse venir dans la
partie libre à l'ouest
pratiquement chacun à collaborer pour
que les gens ne s'étaient de la
communiste s'être amené ça c'était là ma
motivation cette motivation existe
toujours jusqu'à ce jour car personne
n'a pu abolir ce mur poursuivre mon
travail et je ramène ces gens mais ce
mur
c'est le 13 août 1961 qu'on a commencé à
le construire
pourquoi tout commence en 1945 le 11
avril la 9e armée américaine et sur
l'aisne
si on regarde une carte on s'aperçoit
que la lgv c'est très loin en allemand
on est à 130 kilomètres seulement de
berlin et dans l'état où se trouvent les
armées allemandes à cette époque
on se rend compte que aller à berlin ce
n'est pas très difficile on y mettra
trois ou quatre jours les fronts nazis
se sont littéralement effondrés et
pourtant l'armée américaine et les
autres armées alliées ne bougeront pas
de laives elle reste là immobile et
pourquoi
et bien parce que le général eisenhower
en a décidé ainsi le général eisenhower
conforme à la pensée constante du
président roosevelt depuis 1942 le
président ouzbek a choisi de faire
confiance installée dix ont aveuglément
confiance s'installe alors dans cette
perspective eisenhower estime que
l'effort de guerre des russes a été
considérable c'est vrai la dissidente
est que leurs pertes ont été immenses
c'est vrai elles ont été immenses et
qu'il leur appartient de recueillir la
gloire de la prise de berlin
ce sont des très belles idées et
normalement nous pourrions que nous en
féliciter mais nous devons écouter un
autre écho celui du vieux lutteur
churchill tu as tout de même droit de
parler en l'occurrence il dit
les belles idées et la politique ça fait
deux et il dit aussi si nous laissons
les soviétiques qui nous laissons les
russes arrivés en europe centrale il
n'en partiront plus jamais et montgomery
le britannique lemarchal voudrait foncé
on est obligé de le retenir il le
regrettera toute sa vie
alors c'est staline qui prend berlin le
2 mai et le 8 mai vous le savez
l'allemagne capitule et au mois de
juillet les alliés viennent occuper les
secteurs de berlin qui leur ont été
réservés
[Musique]
berlin a des arrondissements les
français ont deux arrondissements les
britanniques en ont 4 les américains en
ont six et les rues sont à 8
mais voilà c'est que la question se pose
berlin est à l'intérieur de la zone
soviétique
comment les alliés de l'ouest vont ils y
accéder on en avait parlé en septembre
44 à londres dans une conférence chargée
de résoudre ce problème et puis là aussi
l'ambassadeur why not
un ami personnel de route belle avait
dit nous n'avons pas demandé des
garanties aux soviétiques
il faut leur faire confiance alors
l'arrêt fait confiance et pour le moment
n'avait pas de texte on avait pas
d'accord on n'avait pas de traiter on
pouvait négocier en juillet 1945 par
monsieur les américains dans leur élan
avaient largement débordé la zone qui
leur avait été réservé et il occupait la
thuringe et la saxe qui devait
normalement revenir aux soviétiques
alors conférence à berlin avec le
maréchal joukov
l'un des vainqueurs de berlin le
principal vainqueur de berlin et les
américains disent nous allons évacuer la
thuringe et la saxe mais alors il faut
que nous signons un accord sur berlin
sur l'accès à berlin réponse de jock of
mercy d'évacuer la thuringe et la saxe
mais je ne signerai aucun traité sur les
accès de berlin vous viendrez comme vous
voudrez ça dépend de nous on fait ça
pour vous faire plaisir
inutile de signer un traité et on ne
signe pas le traite sa-7 extradé
car tout le problème de berlin le drame
la tragédie de berlin car c'est devenu
une tragédie a découlé de cela de la
totale erreur d'optique de la diplomatie
américaine en 1900
nous
[Musique]
on obtient quand même un accord signé ce
sont les aviateurs américains qu'ils
obtiennent il vient de trouver son
coffre et lui disent écoutez monsieur le
maréchal
vous nous avez accordé des corridors
aériens
nos avions y passe et sans arrêt des
chasseurs soviétiques les croire il y
aura fatalement un accident nouveau
signalons que si en un accident au
signal à plusieurs évidemment nous
perdrons du monde mais vous aussi est ce
que c'est votre intérêt zhukov sommes
pragmatiques a dit d'accord nous allons
délimité très exactement ces corridas et
nous allons signer un papier sur cette
délimitation et il faut dire que comme
les soviétiques se conforme au traité
et bien plus tard quand on en arrivera
aux affrontements
quand les soviétiques choisiront de
bloquer berlin partait plus de voies
ferrées plus de routes plus rien eh bien
ils toucheront pas au corridor est hélas
on rêve et on se dit et si on avait eu
un traité un accord écrit sur le reste
olympe alors aux instincts il faut bien
vivre ensemble
et d'ailleurs en 45 la conférence de
potsdam entre staline trauma né at li a
confirmé que chacun des alliés auraient
accès librement à berlin mais
sous-entendu suivants 1
le bon vouloir des russes
en 1948 tout va se gâtent en juin de
cette année là les alliés occidentaux
instituts dans leur zone
un nouveau marque
c'est la réforme monétaire et se marque
sera légal à berlin où est ce qu'il y
aura donc deux marques à berlin celui de
l'est et celui de l'ouest et ça les
soviétiques de l'accepter ils
protestaient violemment et pour marquer
leur hostilité totale il se livre à un
acte catégorique et définitif dans leur
esprit qu'il décide de procéder au
blocus de berne
eh oui l'autoroute est bloquée la voie
ferrée est bloqué or berlin importe tout
tous sont ravis tech toute son énergie
tout ces matières premières destinées à
faire tourner les usines tout alors
puisqu'on a coupé l'autoroute où se
succèdent des files ininterrompues de
camions la voie ferrée où les trains se
succèdent sans cesse eh bien c'est fini
les russes se disent berlin veut
étouffer il ya deux mois de
ravitaillement berlin dans trois mois
sans sera terminé et les occidentaux
capituleront bien raisonner non mal
raisonné
c'est oublier les couloirs aériens
hélas le général le sus clé qui commande
à berlin va avoir l'idée de quelque
chose d'extraordinaire qu'on appellera
le port est rien
et ça c'est une aventure tel qu'il n'y
en a pas d'autres dans l'histoire
contemporaine
c'est fabuleux tous les avions possibles
seront réquisitionnés
ce sera un véritable pont aérien
ils atterriront de secondât secondes sur
les aérodromes de berlin ils apporteront
tout pour les berlinois et les berlinois
pendant des mois presqu'une vont arriver
à survivre grâce au pont aérien quand
l'hiver vient we leave et revient
eh bien il faut chauffer ces gens là
c'est pas l'époque du fuel c'est le
charbon ne rien coûter le faune
extraordinaire de youssouf clés au
général le mec qui commande l'aviation
générale combien d'avions pouvez vous me
donner pour porter du charbon la
communication est très mauvaise et le
média répéter parce que j'entends rien
la communication est affreuse qu'est ce
que vous avez dit combien d'avions pour
porter du charbon c'est ridicule dit le
général le mais j'entends toujours
portée du charbon mais c'est ce qu'il
fallait entendre deal général clé et en
effet on apporte des tonnes et des
centaines et les milliers de tonnes de
charbon par la voie des airs de sorte
que mois de mai 1949 les soviétiques
comprennent que le blocus est inutile
et lève le blocus
le pont aérien a vaincu mais il a coûté
170 millions de dollars aux américains
mais pendant le poker et bien les
occidentaux qui n'ont plus à se gêner on
autoriser de nouvelles élections à
berlin et c'est ernst writer qui a été
élu bourgmestre les soviétiques ont fait
des élections et c'est évidemment un
autre bochum est qui a été élu à berne
est la coupure d'ores et déjà est faite
est un peu après la levée du blocus
à la fin de l'année 1949
eh bien on verra apparaître deux est à
nouveau l'inquiétude ra les contours
exacts des zones d'occupation occidental
l'autre le contour de la zone soviétique
à l'ouest c'est la république fédérale
allemande capital bonne à l'est c'est la
république démocratique allemande
capitale berlin
et oui on tient bien à brandir ses
couleurs berlin on ne renonce pas à
berlin à alès c'est notre capital c'est
notre ville cette enclave dans notre
république
elle n'aura qu'un temps il faudra que
berlin ne nous reviennent et c'est ça le
problème justement alors les années
passent en 1955 il y à une conférence au
sommet les quatre grands se réunissent
pour régler le problème de berlin qui
est toujours pendant inutile parce
qu'ils ne sont rien de cette conférence
et puis il y à un nouveau maître en urss
seddiki ta cote chauffer berlin
intéresse beaucoup
ça devient même la principale de ses
préoccupations
ainsi chacun a repris sa place à l'est
comme à l'ouest mais le courant des
migrations a fait naturellement un bond
en avant
alors pour passer de l'est à l'ouest
il y a bien entendu toute la frontière
entre eux la mer baltique et l'extrême
sud
cette frontière qui fait 13 180 km
[Musique]
et dès 1953 il briche se préoccupe de
barrez cette frontière on avait commencé
déjà bien avant mais maintenant ça
deviendra déjà un mur le premier mur il
est là treize 180 km
[Musique]
alors là quand on arrive c'est terrible
car le no man's land
il a cinq kilomètres de grillages des
chevaux de frise des barbelés tout y est
les miradors les armes automatiques tout
y est on ne peut pas passer et on le
sait tous les gens de l'est qui veulent
venir à l'ouest savent qu'ils ne peuvent
pas passer alors où vont-ils à berlin
mais oui c'est tout simple
parce que d'après les accords les quatre
secteurs sont libres d'accès quelqu'un
qui ne se sent pas bien à dresde
parce que son salaire est trop bas et
les trois mal logés il travaille trop il
est mal vu par la police alors il prend
le train faux père le père laisse là il
prend le métro tout simplement le métro
circule entre les secteurs il arrive à
berlin ouest et là il n'a plus qu'à
partir pour la république fédérale par
le train ou l'avion et ça se passe tout
le temps savez vous combien depuis 1948
d'allemands ont quitté l'allemagne de
l'est pour l'ouest 4 millions la
population de la norvège alors berlin
devient le sujet de préoccupation numéro
un à la fois de valter olbricht le
maître de la rda mais de khrouchtchev le
nouveau maître de l'urss
nikita khrouchtchev et en 58 et en 59
kotcheff commence à parler beaucoup de
berlin il y faudrait faire une ville
libre à berlin ouest sous le contrôle de
la rda comment le contrôle de la rda ça
voudrait dire que plus personne ne
pourrait aller à berlin ouest ou plutôt
ne pourrait en sortir alors les gens de
l'est s'affole d'avantagé de recherche
se ruent à berlin alors il n'y a parmi
ces émigrés 50% de jeunes de moins de 25
ans pourquoi parce qu'ils ont fait leurs
études à l'est
excellente étude et dès qu'ils ont leur
diplôme et bien ils vont s'établir en
allemagne de l'ouest il ya également
parmi les adultes des médecins des
avocats des ingénieurs des ouvriers
spécialisés beaucoup d'ouvriers
spécialisés des artisans enfin les sens
vives de la nation et la productivité
baisse
on manque de main d'oeuvre
partout dans une ville comme al en 1960
la production baissera de 50% dans une
autre de 70 % c'est l'hémorragie c'est
tragique
l'allemagne de l'est est le seul pays où
le taux des naissances croix et où la
population baisse et on s'est dit ça ne
pourra pas durer toujours
et à d'ailleurs un sénateur américain
qui le dit il s'appelle fulbright qui
dit mais pourquoi les styles leur
population s'en aller comme ça moi à
leur place mais très un mur bah oui
c'est un américain qui a prononcé ce mot
le premier il aurait mieux fait de
s'abstenir vous en êtes d'accord mais le
3 juin 1960 et khrouchtchev va
rencontrer kennedy à vienne
kennedy qui vient d'être élu président
des états unis depuis très peu de moi
c'est leur première rencontre et
khrouchtchev tape sur la tabaski à de
croce yacout chef détendu heureux
agréable qui fait des plaisanteries et
puis à khrouchtchev qui fonce kata et ce
jour là il a choisi d'attaquer il dit
c'est insensé il ya seize ans que la
guerre est finie et nous n'avons pas
signé de traité de paix avec l'allemagne
c'est vous qui ne voulez pas eh bien
puisque vous ne voulez pas je vais
signer seul un traité avec la rda tant
pis pour vous et on fera une ville libre
à berlin et kennedy lee vous voulez la
guerre c'est vous qui voulez la guerre
des crochets et quand le signerait vous
votre fameux traité dit kennedy avant
décembre de cette année alors dit
kennedy l'hiver sera froid et ils se
séparent sans cordialité alors le cc en
allemagne de l'est et le courant des
migrations s'accroît on en était à peu
près à 11 cents par jour ce qui était
énorme maintenant des dettes à 2000 à
3000 certains jours à 4 milles par jour
alors il y a dans un secteur de berlin
au nord à marianne fel d'immenses quand
ce sont des immeubles on a réquisitionné
24 immeubles pour recevoir les réfugiés
avec tout le personnel le matériel
nécessaire est maintenant juin à 61
il faut réquisitionner 29 autres
immeubles
[Musique]
15 juin 1960 et valter ulbricht annonce
une conférence de presse c'est au
ministère de l'air l'ancien ministère de
l'air de goering et c'est dans la salle
des banquets ou goering a reçue si
souvent ces aviateurs
il ya une estrade valter une brusque et
sur cette estrade et ont entendu du
drapeau rouge partout et 350
journalistes qui viennent de l'est et de
l'ouest on parle de tas de choses et un
moment donné liang journalistes du
frankfurter rundschau qui trouvent qu'on
tourne un peu trop autour du pot qui
demande la parole qui dit monsieur le
président si vous faites une ville libre
à berlin comme on l'a dit est ce qu'elle
sera barrée du reste du monde elle aura
une brèche ce qui n'est pas un homme
très gai très expansif il est glacial on
a toujours l'impression qu'il a avalé un
parapluie à ce moment-là ullrich se
fâche il devient tout rouge écarlate il
dit mais enfin madame vous êtes donc de
ceux qui croient que nous voulons
construire un mur autour de berlin ouest
et bien détrompez vous il y a des maçons
à berlin s mais il travaille à temps
complet
nous n'avons pas de besoin de maçons
nous ne construirons pas de mu
[Musique]
alors la conférence de presse le soir
même et transmises par la télévision est
allemand voilà de quoi être rassuré non
parce qu'on transmet le même soir un
discours de khrouchtchev probablement
doubler dans lequel compte chef avec sa
figure des mauvais jours 10 mai c'est
insupportable
je vais signer un traité séparé avec
l'allemagne de l'est avec la rda et nous
ferons une ville libre de berlin c'est
très contradictoires alors le flot des
réfugiés s'accroît encore mais en
juillet c'est plus difficile déjà de
passer à l'ouest parce qu'on arrête les
vopos arrête dans le métro tous les
allemands de l'est y porte une valise et
souvent il les renvoie
et puis le 7 août une note des pays
signataires du pacte de varsovie
parvient ulbricht on lui fait savoir
qu'il est urgent de barret sa frontière
en somme il a le feu vert alors le doze
c'est un samedi il fait beau fait chaud
24 degrés rien de spécial les deux ans
une vive normalement comme l ont
toujours vécu
le soir c'est un samedi donc que on voit
beaucoup de voitures qui vont à l'est
sont les familles qui aime bien se voir
le samedi
samedi soir à 22h30 pourtant les gens
qui sont dans le métro ce métro qui
circulent parfaitement librement entre
les zones ont la surprise de voir les
rames s'arrêter dans les gares on leur
dit c'est fini rentrez chez vous le
métro ne fonctionne plus qu'à pourquoi
et puis à 22h30 le général hoffman au
ministère de la défense de la rda dans
berlin convoque les officiers supérieurs
police et armée et leur dit ceci le
camarade valter ulbricht a décidé de
fermer la frontière à zéro heure quinze
donc c'est décidé c'est fait
et c'est imminent et on distribue à la
même heure des mitraillettes dans les
casernes aux soldats et aux policiers de
berne est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il y a de part et d'autre de la
porte de brandebourg cette porte
admirable qui est un symbole de ce
berlin cherche à survivre et bien d'un
côté il ya les soviétiques la porte et
dans la zone soviétique mais pas très
loin et de l'autre côté il y à des
postes de policiers de l'allemagne de
l'ouest les vopos à l'est les choupo à
l'ouest et ce soir là les choupo
s'appelle chemoul da schulz shrader tout
s'est bien passé n'ont vu les voitures
rentrer les gens qui avaient été
festoyer rentrer chez eux
et puis ensuite le calme plat jusque
vers une heure du matin 1h du matin tout
à coup une cohue de piétons qui arrivent
ils sont exaspérés ces piétons il ya des
femmes qui seraient prêts à pleurer mais
qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qui a bien
voilà il ya plus de métro et oui il est
resté il était resté chez leurs amis ou
dans leur famille jusqu'à peu après
minuit et puis tout à coup elle en
prendre le métro s'était aperçue qu'il y
en avait plus alors ils rentraient à
pied c'est pas très agréable si vous
allez à berlin vers estime ans vers la
plus belle baie mais traverser tous à
pied
on comprend qu'ils ne soient pas
contents et alors cette cohue d'un
défilé au poste d'entrée à berlin ouest
pendant assez longtemps pour finalement
perdre 2 heures du matin plus personne
mme à 2 heures du matin soultz qui est
tout seul les autres se sont assis à
l'intérieur de la cabane voit tout à
coup la porte de brandebourg qui était
totalement illuminée il la voit
s'éteindre plus projecteurs et entre les
colonnes doriques un camion qui s'avance
qui s'avance qui s'avance vu presque
jusqu'à la limite les rails du tramway
qui servait de limites et la douze
hommes sont à terre ils ont des
mitraillettes et se met en ligne sur les
rails du tramway pour barrer le passage
à tous à 100 tout voiture à tout piéton
il est stupéfait et schultz et il va
tout de suite téléphoné
on prévient le commissaire de police du
quartier du tiergarten est un peu plus
tard un autre camion
qui franchit la porte qui s'arrête ce
sont des miliciens qui jette à terre des
énormes rouleaux de fils de fer barbelés
un peu plus tard des camions apporte des
chevaux de frise d'autres camions
apporte des normes poteau de ciment que
l'on va planter qui vont servir d'appui
aux barbelés
[Musique]
alors on prévient tout de suite les
autorités mais alors même moule n'a
children voit ce spectacle étonnant le
même spectacle se produit tout autour
des 162 km du mur de ce qui sera le mur
le périmètre qui entoure berlin ouest
qui va peu à peu être emmuré
[Musique]
alors comment va-t-on réagi et bien les
autorités de berlin ouest vont appeler
bonne la capitale bien sûr fédéral et à
bonn on préviendra les américains
lesquels américains seront prévenus à
berlin auparavant et ça n'est quand même
qu'à 11 heures du matin que le premier
message pour washington partira de
bonnes il arrivera au département d'état
qui dort scar 11h à bones et 5h à
washington et là on décortiquera les
messages pour en faire un rapport et
c'est le secrétaire d'état jean risque à
11 heures du matin heure américaine qui
appellera le président kennedy lequel
c'est dimanche va monter sur son yacht
le melvin et va lui dire rassurez vous
monsieur le président il ya un incident
mais c'est pas très grave
alors il part rassuré pas très grave
curieux que l'on ait cette réaction
or on l'a prévenu également les
commandants militaires
ils sont trois à l'ouest il ya le
général watson 2 qui est le commandant
américain
il y a le général la com qui est le
français il ya le général rohan de
lacombe très beau nom français mais qui
est le bree tanner et là il se réunit à
la commande d'un touriste réunissent à
la kommandantur et discute les rapports
s'accumulent sur leur bureau et il en
arrive à cette conclusion
il reste 13 points de passage y en avait
13 en effet encore ce matin là les
alliés peuvent passer au fond il n'y a
que les allemands de l'est qui ne
peuvent plus passer c'est une affaire
intérieure allemande qui regardent la
police allemand ouais facilement vaincu
et willy brandt le bourgmestre
social-démocrate de berlin mais n'est
pas là il n'est pas berlin il est en
train de faire sa campagne électorale
1961 seller l'énorme campagne électorale
qui secoue l'allemagne
on vient le prévenir il saute dans un
taxi l'aéroport un avion il arrive à
berlin et les généraux sont encore en
place
discute toujours à la kommandantur et
willy brandt fait irruption à la
commande date aurait dit qu'est ce que
vous allez faire mais sur les généraux
et les généraux 10 nous en avons discuté
nous avons prévenu nos gouvernements en
fait c'est une affaire intérieure
allemande ne l'avons pas l'intention
d'intervenir
comment dénouer les bandes mais enfin
envoyer au moins des patrouilles le long
de la frontière je ne dis pas pour
affronter les forces est allemande
je dis tout simplement pour réconforter
le moral des berlinois qui en ont bien
besoin montrer qu'ils ne sont pas
abandonnés à non nous ne pouvons pas le
faire
10 les généraux mais nous avons pris une
décision alors willy brandt est plein
d'espoir d'une telle décision importante
nous allons déposer une protestation
écrite sous sur le bureau du commandant
soviétique de berne
alors là les bras lui en tombent à ce
pauvre vue libre et d'écouté si vous ne
faites que ça c'est un immense éclat de
rire qui se court à tout l'est depuis
berlin jusqu'à vladivostok et s'en va
furieux alors les gens vont se réveiller
le lendemain matin justement et trophées
guerrilla ces barbelés ces hommes
mitraillette au poing la ville
entièrement cercle est plus possible de
passer mais justement il y en a qui
veulent passer
ils se disent bon ce sera plus grave
demain plus sérieux encore après demain
on peut peut-être encore passé
[Musique]
ceux qui sont passés dit venez venez
vous ne pourrez peut-être plus demain et
non non disent les autres c'est vrai
c'est facile à dire venez mais quand on
a sa maison sa famille ses amis son
travail son passé on n'a pas toujours
envie de partir on n'emporte pas sa
patrie à la semelle de ses souliers a
dit tantôt alors il reste comment
va-t-on réagir au moins maintenant mais
on ne va pas réagir et le drame c'est ça
c'est que ces berlinois attend attendent
un geste un acte le chancelier adenauer
a bien fait un communiqué il a dit il
faut que nos compatriotes de berlin et
confiance mais c'est tellement lénifiant
que c'est accablant de tristesse et un
journal suisse dira ça représente
ça ressemble à ces cartes postales que
les pères de familles envoient des
vacances bons baisers à tous et ils ont
l'impression d'être seul alors
évidemment dans les jours qui suivent
les tentatives d'évasion se multiplient
on peut passer encore par des ruses tout
n'est pas encore hermétiquement clos ya
notamment une rue la bernauerstrasse
avec des fenêtres qui donnent
directement sur l'ouest au pape amath un
mur en bas on placerait le mur à l'ouest
alors il ya des gens qui vont sauter par
la fenêtre du rez-de-chaussée lé vos
pots viendront mur et la fenêtre du
rez-de-chaussée
[Musique]
on
alors ils sauteront du premier étage on
mesurera le premier étage alors ils sont
rendus de second étage on mesurera le
second étage
[Musique]
m
alors le 22 août une femme saute du
troisième étage et se tue en tombant
c'est la première mort tu aimais
et elle brille jetaient khrouchtchev ne
veulent plus qu'il y ait ce genre
d'exemple donc peu à peu le mur
provisoire devient un mur définitif les
fameux masson qui parait-il
travaillaient à temps complet sont
réquisitionnés
et maintenant ce sont des briques ce
sont des moellons ce sont des pierres
qui vont former le mur le mur avec un
ante m
[Musique]
oh
mais le même vin 2 ou propre chef hasard
d'un nouveau pion il est évident qu'ils
jouent de plus en plus fort alors il
décide que désormais les soldats alliés
occidentaux qui voudront passer dans le
secteur soviétique devront montrer leurs
papiers aux vocaux les américains
envoient quatre soldats sans papiers on
les arrête
mais on les relâche alors que je trouve
autre chose contrôle obligatoire des
vols civils vers berlin
là les alliés répondent non
[Musique]
entre-temps khrouchtchev a annoncé qu'il
allait reprendre ses essais nucléaires
qu'il allait fabriquer une bombe de 100
mégatonnes kennedy qui ne veut pas
demeurer en reste a dit moi aussi je
reprends mes essais nucléaires à paris
de gaulle a réuni une retentissante
conférence de presse déclarant qu'il ne
faut pas tolérer ce qui n'est pas
tolérable et khrouchtchev qui est maître
dans ce genre de jeu sans qu'il a été
trop loin
ou plutôt il sait comme disait cocteau
jusqu'où il ne faut pas aller trop loin
il a dit devant des témoins très peu de
temps vous savez j'étais ouvrier
métallurgiste je sais très bien que
quand un métal a été chauffé à blanc je
sais très bien le moyen de le faire
refroidir
alors tout à coup il a envie de voir
paul henri spaak qui est le ministre des
affaires étrangères de belgique mais
aussi l'ancien secrétaire général de
l'onu et lui fait savoir qu'il aimerait
bien que ce pack bien lui rendre une
petite visite spa qui va et à moscou
tout à coup khrouchtchev complètement
transport mais qui plaisante qui est
agréable qui raconte des histoires
ludiques goûter voilà tout ça il faut
que ça s'arrête vous je sais très bien
que vous occidentaux vous ne pouvez pas
vous laisser marcher sur les orteils oui
c'est la phrase qui a été noté par ce
pas alors c'est pâques dit bah je suis
content de vous voir arriver à de
meilleurs sentiments oui du coach je ne
veux pas signer ce fameux traité paix
séparée parce que je pense qu'en effet
ça vous met dans une situation difficile
à l'occident ces packs respire de plus
en présumant fin monsieur le président
vous ne vous rendez pas compte que avec
tout ce que vous avez fait depuis
quelques semaines ça a été très grasse
angers vous avez arrêté un convoi
militaire américain sur l'autoroute
oui oui du coach f non enfin ça ne
pouvait pas aller très loin comment
elles ont prouvé à déboucher sur un
conflit armé et qui sait la guerre on
décroche pas sur scène il ya quelques
temps on a jugé un pêcheur devant un
tribunal en russie chez nous c'est ce
qu'il avait fait il des boulonnais les
rails des chemins de fer alors l'arrêter
hall la juge
le juge lui a dit mme enfin pourquoi
enleviez vous les boulons des rails et
ce pêcheur à diversité pour lester mes
filets du jugement favori et ce que vous
avez conscience que les trains auraient
pu dérailler
non non monsieur le juge a dit ou camara
du a dit le pêcheur je laissais toujours
assez de boulons pour que les trains ne
déraille pas mais ça je crois que c'est
la meilleure explication par
khrouchtchev lui même de sa propre
politique
alors tout ça évidemment s'est calmée
mais le mur
restait le mur bien en place qui avait
pris sa forme définitive au fond est-ce
qu'on n'avait pas fait tout ce bruit
pour faire oublier que maintenant ce mur
on l'avait édifié pour jamais
alors les berlinois ont dû vivre avec ce
et vivre avec l'histoire de ceux qui
sans cesse tenté de franchir ce mur il y
avait eu d'abord un policier un soldat
de l'armée populaire et celui là avait
été abattu par ses camarades entre les
deux lignes entre les deux murs dans le
no man's land et le général clé que
kennedy avait envoyé là s'était fâché
avait dit comment avons nous pu nous
américains laisser mourir sous nos yeux
ce soldat il n'était pas content de la
manière dont la maison blanche serait
freinée toutes ces initiatives clés et l
homme qui disait chaque fois que les
russes avancent un pion nous devons en
avance et un autre est à washington on
me disait attention attention attention
n'allez pas trop loin clés à demander à
être rappelé
et quelques temps pour le départ du
général clé ce sera un autre drame
[Musique]
deux jeunes ouvriers de berlin-est ils
ont 18 ans tous les deux peter fechter
et son camarade hellmuth décide de
passer le mur qu'ils en ont assez
alors il on perd un endroit où croit-il
on peut passer par ce que il suffit de
franchir un long barrage de barbelés
ensuite on aura dit m et puis on pourra
d'un grand élan peut-être franchir le
mur et ce jour là au milieu de la
journée vers midi ils se hasarde et ils
franchissent les barbelés qui se déchire
de partout bien sûr mais ils ont passé
alors il courait ces pétards festayres
qui atteint le premier le mur il
pourrait sauter mais il attend on ne
sait pas ce qui l'attend hellmuth le
rejoint et lui un élan énorme il passe
et il appelle petter tu viens tu viens
et pétain comme paralysés figé on ne
sera pas pourquoi il n'a pas sauté et
tout à coup évidemment lui tire dessus
et on l'atteint une balle dans le ventre
une balle dans le dos il temps et ils
eurent il crie cet effrayant c'est
déchirant c'est lamentable les gens à
court tout le long du mur on est là les
coudes appuyé sur le mur on se hisse
comme on peut on le voit et il crie
venez venez à mon ce que et c'est
affreux parce qu'on ne peut rien faire
les vopos sont là sur leurs miradors
larmes visant alors il ya des policiers
de l'ouest qui lui jettent des
pansements mais les trop faibles il ne
peut pas ramper jusqu'à ses pansements
on averti les américains c'est à deux
pas du point de passage
checkpoint charlie comme andy et les
américains téléphone au général watson
watson 2 qui dit est-ce qu'ils sont à
l'est
oui généralement général ils sont à
l'est alors n'intervenez pas et puis les
minutes pas s'épiler berlinois coup et
même voilà le camion de la télévision va
filmer l'agonie de peter fechter et puis
on va lancer les américains vous n'avez
pas le droit
watson est assailli de toutes parts
alors il ne sait plus que faire ils
appellent washington
il veut parler au président kennedy il à
l'aide de camp du président clayton qui
dit on ne peut pas déranger le président
il est en conférence écouté lui parlerai
tout à l'heure attendait si vous voulez
bien
alors il attend watts et puis c'est
insupportable
l'homme râle maintenant les heures ont
passé cet homme est en train de mourir
en public
il ya les américains qui regardent les
berlinois qui regardent les vopos qui
regarde
alors évidemment il y aura de terribles
manifestations dans berlin
manifestation dans la ville même devant
l'hôtel de ville les puits tentative
d'assaut du mur qui sera brisée par les
policiers de ville et brandt
parce que peut pas aller jusque là on me
l'est même des soldats soviétiques et
puis peu à peu tout revient dans l'ordre
parce que les berlinois doivent
comprendre qu'ils sont vraiment seule et
à partir de ce moment-là n'y en a pas
qu'il ait compris au oui je sais bien le
président john kennedy est venu à bâle
il a été acclamé comme personne n'est
jamais acclamé il est allé jusqu'au mur
il a regardé il a touché le mur et il a
dit devant tous les micros ich bin ein
berliner je suis un berlinois des belles
paroles mais les berlinois l'ont su très
vite ce n'était que de belles paroles
alors pour franchir le mur en risque la
mort ou bien si l'on ait repris vivent
de très longues années de prison et
pourtant sans cesse depuis 1961
des hommes et des femmes tenteront de
franchir le mur
c'est le 25 avril 1981
j'ai franchi le mur illégalement en 1979
j'ai été emprisonné j'ai fait une
demande pour pouvoir partir mais elle a
été refusée
il fallait donc que je réalise la chose
de manière illégale
je suis parti car c'était arrangé par
des gens de berlin ouest à falcon 1e r d
un
ils m'ont envoyé un terrain g expliquant
la franchise ans puis je suis allé voir
ensuite je suis allé avec une échelle à
l'endroit prévu pour fuir avec ricky
berens david
l'un est gens nous avons repéré
l'endroit et le 25 avril deux heures du
matin nous sommes évadés illégalement en
passant trois clôtures et la clôture de
signalisation ainsi que le barrage anti
chars pendant le passage de la frontière
les vos pauses de la rda nous ont tiré
dessus
il était très difficile de passer mais
nous avons réussi
comme je vous le dis depuis le 25 avril
je suis citoyen
certains réussiront il y aura 72 morts
et 106 blessés
les tentatives d'évasion bien on
pourrait en parler pendant des heures
elles sont quelques fois cocasse
d'autres émouvant d'autres dramatique
je pense par exemple à cette jeune femme
qu'un occidental elle était toute petite
évidemment elle peser 45 kg qu'un
occidental à passer dans sa valise car
tout le monde peut pas le faire je pense
aussi à cette tentative réussie de
passage dans une voiture on fouille les
voitures moi même ma voiture a été
fouillée il ya très peu de temps alors à
cette époque là encore bien plus mais il
y avait une petite voiture cette époque
il appelé les états
tu te places à l'avant et puis derrière
un moteur occuper toute la place
derrière alors évidemment impossible de
mettre quelqu'un derrière ne regarde pas
derrière voitures passent mais en fait
le propriétaire de lise et sam avait
enlevé le moteur qui était derrière et
il avait mis à la place un tout petit
moteur de deux roues qui pouvait
évidemment propulser la voiture pendant
peu de temps puisqu'il y avait à peine
un ou deux litres d'essence maroc qui
pouvait la faire avancer et à la place
dans la toute petite place réservée une
personne pouvait se blottir tu étais pas
très confortable enfin le passage il y
aurait 20 minutes on pouvait le faire
[Musique]
et cette voiture elle est actuellement
au musée du mur qui est à check point
charlie
aujourd'hui même mais où se trouve
rappeler toutes ces évasions
[Musique]
oh
je m'appelle karine et celle 25
septembre 1979 que j'ai été dénoncée est
arrêtée pour propos subversifs contre
l'état et puis nous mars 1980 j'ai été
condamné à 16 mois de prison
j'étais en possession de livres
interdits devenir mannequin c'est faux
que ces graphes et j'ai donné ses livres
des amis c'était la raison de mon
arrestation j'ai passé neuf mois des
seize quel j'étais condamné dans les
prisons de garde march d'arrêt de
steinberg et en juillet 1981 je suis
arrivé en allemagne de l'ouest
avant je n'avais pas eu de raison venir
en allemagne de l'ouest mais pendant mon
séjour en prison
je ne voyais pas comment continuer à
vivre en rda
j'étais d'accord pour être déchu de la
nationalité
maintenant chéri depuis deux ans en
république fédérale
il ya aussi l'histoire du tunnel ya eu
beaucoup de tunnels dans cette histoire
mais celui-là c'est celui de 1964 40
étudiants qui étaient à l'ouest qui
avaient des amis des parents à l'est ont
décidé de les faire passer alors ils ont
loué une maison à la bernerie à un
appartement plutôt dans une maison de la
bernauerstrasse je vous ai parlé de la
bernauerstrasse avec ses façades qui
était à l'est mais une rue ça de côté
l'autre côté longer le mur
alors ils ont loué un appartement au
rez-de-chaussée avec une cale et ils ont
commencé à creuser
d'abord un puits dans la cave 14 mètres
et ensuite une galerie qui devait passer
sous le mur
ils ont mis des mois et plusieurs mois
présent débouché dans ce qu'il croyait
être la cave d'un immeuble en face et
qui est en fait une fosse d'aisance
il manque
n'avait pas prévu ça heureusement elle
était désaffecté ne restait plus que
l'odeur ils ont traversé ont débouché
dans la cour ils ont envoyé des
télégrammes à tous ceux qui avaient
souhaité passer et tous ces hommes ces
femmes ces enfants sont arrivés de
partout et en en 48 heures deux jours et
deux nuits ont pu s'engouffrer dans le
tunnel rampé jusqu'à l'ouest
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
le dernier soir malheureusement la
police est arrivée elle arrive toujours
la police les derniers passeur se sont
engouffrés dans le tunnel et le tout
dernier n'était pas encore entré dans le
tunnel lorsque la police est allemande a
ouvert le feu alors lui s'est défendu il
a tiré à son tour il a abattu un
policier est allemand un certain schult
car tous ces hommes sont des allemands
ces sales draps schult est mort
les autres sont plus tous passés il faut
quand même penser à schult parce qu'on
peut penser que schulz lui aussi est une
victime du mur de berlin
j'ai grandi en rda j'ai commencé à
écrire des textes qui ont dit plus
j'avais des contacts avec des personnes
en pologne et en tchéquie slovaquie ce
qui était également indésirables en
1970-71 j'étais condamné à deux ans de
prison pour agitation subversives
j'ai été libéré mais j'avais coupé les
ponts je ne devais plus trouver un
travail normal
oui nous ne place à l'université j'ai
alors essayé en 1977 impact mon ami se
soit évadée de franchir le mur mais ma
tentative fut un échec
j'ai été quatre mois en détention
préventive mais j'étais libéré parce
qu'il n'y avait pas assez de preuves
contre moi en été en 1978 je fais une
nouvelle tentative de fuite avec mon
épouse par la tchécoslovaquie
car nous pensions ce serait moins
dangereux on disait qu'il n'y avait pas
de champs de mines n'ont malheureusement
pas réussi
nous avons été à nouveau un certain
temps en détention préventive et en
novembre 1978 avec l'aide d'amis de
berlin-ouest la fuite a réussi par
helmstedt sur le transit dans le coffre
d'une voiture
et maintenant j'habite ici c'est tout
alors il ya aussi ces deux familles qui
sont parties en montgolfière tel de
famille qu'il voulait pas être séparés
alors ils ont d'abord cousue
l'enveloppent de la montgolfière ils ont
acheté des tissus dans différents
endroits pour que ça ne se remarque pas
ensuite l'un des hommes qui était un
bricoleur à bricoler la nacelle avec lé
réchou le propane qui devait envoyer
leur show dans la montgolfière est
d'ailleurs cette nacelle elle est
également au musée du mur
[Musique]
je suppose c'est normal dit non et puis
se sont envolés elles ont atterri à
l'ouest
il
[Musique]
que l'exploit
non
[Musique]
on
mais la dernière morte du mur n'est que
de 1987 une jeune fille
qui s'appelait marie et qui avait 18 ans
alors aujourd'hui quand on se promène
près du mur ce que j'ai fait j'ai erré
longtemps le long du mur
eh bien on trouve ce mur couvert
d'inscriptions dans toutes les langues
certaines de ces inscriptions évoque la
liberté dans toutes les langues mais
d'autres sont seulement des mots d'amour
écrits par des garçons pour défi ou des
filles pour les garçons et qu'ils ont
signé
[Musique]
et
on
[Musique]
et puis quand on avance le long du mur
on voit des gens qu'ils font là leur
jogging des cyclistes qui se promènent
des gens qui dans l'herbe au pied du mur
font la sieste ou bien des amoureux qui
s'embrassent
[Musique]
tant il est vrai que sous tous les
régimes et malgré toutes les polices
c'est la vie qui triomphe
mais est-ce que vous ne croyez pas que
le mur en l'occurrence est une insulte à
la vie
[Musique]